nos dicen que millones de
estadounidenses usan cafeína para
despertar por la mañana lo cual es
cierto aunque si yo tomara café por la
mañana no podría dormir en la noche
porque soy muy sensible abajo se muestra
información nutricional de algunas
bebidas populares en una cafetería muy
bien aquí tenemos diferentes nombres de
bebidas acá tenemos el tipo de la bebida
y parece que esto nos indica si es
caliente o fría aquí tenemos las
calorías que contienen esas bebidas aquí
tenemos el contenido de azúcar en gramos
para cada una de esas bebidas y acá
tenemos la cafeína en miligramos que
contiene cada bebida entonces nos
preguntan los individuos en este
conjunto de datos son y tenemos tres
opciones los clientes de la cafetería
las bebidas de la cafetería o los
contenidos de cafeína ahora debemos ser
cuidadosos cuando alguien dice los
individuos en un conjunto de datos no
necesariamente se refiere a personas los
individuos podrían ser cosas y los
individuos
el conjunto de datos cada uno de estos
renglones se refiere a un cierto tipo de
bebida de la cafetería de modo que los
diferentes tipos de bebidas que se
ofrecen en la cafetería son los
individuos de este conjunto de datos así
que son las bebidas de la cafetería
después nos preguntan el conjunto de
datos contiene y nos dicen cuántas
variables hay y cuántas de esas
variables son categóricas si vemos aquí
arriba veamos las variables esta primera
columna nos indica esencialmente el tipo
de bebida esto no es una variable esto
es un identificador pero todas estas
columnas representan variables por
ejemplo tipo es una variable la bebida
puede ser caliente o fría y solo puede
tomar un valor definido fría o caliente
el valor de esta variable solo puede ser
de una categoría o de otra y no se
limita a sólo dos categorías podríamos
tener más de dos categorías esta
variable podría tomar muchos valores
diferentes por lo que esta variable es
una variable categórica calorías no es
una variable categórica podríamos tener
algo con 4.1 calorías o tener algo con
178 calorías estos valores no los
encontramos en una lista predefinida
sucede con azúcar y con cafeína estas
son variables cuantitativas que no solo
encajan en una categoría por lo tanto yo
diría que tenemos cuatro variables 1 2 3
4 una de las cuales es categórica así
que la respuesta es la opción
y terminamos